en esta obra cercano sí las temperaturas
alcanzan hasta 38 grados hoy Entonces
estos profesionales se adaptan
empezamos un poco más temprano y
terminamos un poco más temprano también
ajustamos un poco todo en función de
cada persona en otros lugares también el
ya empezó más temprano como aquí en
donde los deportistas son más
madrugadores es el mejor momento en un
día como hoy antes de que empiece a
hacer demasiado calor hay más oxígeno
temprano en la mañana tenemos más aire
todos vinieron a refrescarse bajo los
árboles
hacemos lo máximo que podemos afuera en
la mañana y en la tarde hacemos juegos
de mesa nos quedamos en casa y otra vez
salimos en la noche también se adapta la
comida cuando hace calor prefiero comer
cosas frescas como una ensalada dejó la
carne intentó refrescarme un poco en
total nueve departamentos están bajo
alerta naranja por la canícula una ola
de calor caracterizada entre otras cosas
por un bajo descenso de temperaturas
entre el día y la noche
normalmente en la noche cuando caen las
temperaturas el cuerpo puede descansar
pero estos días las temperaturas No
bajan en la noche entonces el cuerpo no
puede descansar
en riñón unos voluntarios visitan a los
adultos mayores los más débiles frente a
la canícula estoy muerto de cansancio
para protegerlos la alcaldía implementó
un dispositivo de vigilancia
primero les preguntamos Cómo se sienten
con estas altas temperaturas le
recomendamos no salir entre las 2D y las
dos y en la tarde salir más bien A
última hora de la tarde les pedimos
cerrar las contraventanas para evitar
que el calor entre en su domicilio les
preguntamos si tienen climatización
tomar duchas beber agua regularmente y
comer saludablemente también son gestos
a adoptar por todos